police released evidence this week in
hopes of catching the killer
behind the biggest unsolved murder case
in new york's history
it's been 10 years since the discovery
of the first victims of the long island
serial killer
over time 10 bodies were found near a
remote beach
erin moriarty shows us what we've
learned about the killer for this week's
48 hours missy can can't forget the late
night phone calls she received from her
sister marine brainer barnes
in the summer of 2007. she called at a
train station in
new york from penn station
i could hear the commotion from the
train station
from the time that she called me it was
poof she was gone
investigators tracked maureen's phone to
a cell tower in long island
they knew that there was something very
very wrong here
three years later in december of 2010
human remains were found along ocean
parkway near gilgo beach
on long island dominic varone then chief
of detectives
was struck by an odd detail it seemed to
be
wrapped in in burlap which
didn't make any sense and the surprises
kept coming
i'm called and chief we found another
set of remains
they find another one and another one we
were dealing with
a serial killer eventually ten sets of
remains were recovered
missy's sister maureen and three others
were found first
and dubbed the gilgo four discarded in a
similar fashion
they were placed roughly 500 feet apart
each wrapped in burlap i think burlap
was selected because
its ability to take dampness moisture
and breathe which would promote decay
as well as act as camouflage they shared
other striking similarities
but they're all 4 foot 11 very petite
hazel
green eyes this killer has a type right
today former fbi agent geraldine hart
now police commissioner
is breathing new life in the case we
believe
that the belt was handled by the suspect
and did not belong
to any of the victims the belt belonged
to a large male says heart
hoping someone will recognize it and
come forward
a very complex case but i can tell you
that we are fully committed to this
investigation
what i want most is answers and justice
and i also want that the world to know
like my sister mattered
and aaron moriarty joins us now good
morning erin i can't believe it's been
10 years already this is such a haunting
case
what else do investigators know about
the killer
anthony good morning it is a haunting
case and this is what we do know from
investigators
we know that the gilgal four were killed
were all four killed by
one killer and that he didn't just drop
the bodies off at once and so
investigators believe he
is very familiar with long island
and here's something really interesting
one of the investigators told me
he had to have a cover story because
he's going back
back and forth to the ocean parkway
where he's leaving the bodies
so that he may have posed as a private
trash collector or a hunter and he also
probably was harmless looking but he has
a cruel streak because he called the
little sister
of one of the victims in 2009 and told
her he had killed her sister
that's right i remember that story why
haven't there been any arrests after all
these years
well anthony it's very difficult to
identify a serial killer because they're
not connected with their victor
with their victims but in this case
there was a police chief who took over
the department from 2012 to 2015
who inexplicably cut out outside
agencies and then engaged in a cover-up
to cover his own misdeeds and that
certainly hindered the investigation all
right aaron
thank you very much aaron moriarty you
can watch aaron's report the hunt for
the long island serial killer
tomorrow night at 10 9 central right
here on cbs